[Musique]
cinq aires qui a lancé une vaste
campagne de dépistage gratuit la ville
qui nous vous en parlions dès vendredi
dernier est soumise à une forte présence
du variant anglais sur l'ensemble de
l'agglomération
cela pourrait s'expliquer par les fêtes
clandestines liés au carnaval si on
arrivait dans toutes les communes de
france à tester les eaux usées dans
toutes les
tous les enseignants de france on leur
donne à des tests mais enseignements
mais les journalistes qui est médecin
tous les gens qui vont travailler on
fera quoi on saurait n'aurait une
cartographie du virus et on saurait donc
le jour on prendra la décision de
confiner qu'il faut probablement
confinés dans tel endroit mais pas dans
l autre c'est ce qu'on annonce qui va se
faire
oui et après tout c'est une bonne
stratégie ça consiste isolé ou et les
zones orient lesquelles e
il n'y a plus de contaminations et à
rendre ces zones le plus étanche
possible de manière que c'est une bonne
solution de repas c'est la notion je ne
dis pas que c'est là que je suis au
moins la solution c'est le vaccin rien
ne serait pire que de lever les
contraintes certes lourde mais ô combien
nécessaire au mauvais moment
trop tôt relâcher notre vigilance
maintenant c'est courir le risque de
contraintes plus fortes dans un avenir
proche
et parmi ceux qui se sont fait vacciner
nicolas sarkozy selon des informations
de l'express que nous sommes en mesure
de confirmer
l'ancien président âgé de 70 ans a reçu
sa première injection le mois dernier à
l'hôpital percy de clamart
pour l'instant les moins de 75 ans ne
sont pas concernés par la vaccination
sauf en cas de pathologies graves on
ignore donc ce qui justifie la
vaccination de l'ancien président le
nombre de cyberattaques a quadruplé en
un an en france des systèmes
informatiques trop vulnérable face à des
cybercriminels de plus en plus organisée
alors la france veut désormais faire de
la cyber sécurité une priorité avec
annonce d'un plan global
les cyber attaques ont de toute façon de
manière très claire ils ciblent le
maillon le plus vulnérable et il
s'appuie sur les négligences 6 milliards
d'euros c'est le montant de la facture
du coc vide pour les villes en 2020
achats de masques de gel aide aux
familles tourisme en baisse la note est
salée
elles revendiquent leur attaque sous des
noms énigmatique
ryuk netwalker d'opel penner leur mode
opératoire crypter les données d'une
entreprise et réclamé une rançon des
organisations criminelles souvent basés
en europe de l'est mais qui agissent
dans le monde entier des comptes dans le
rouge à une perte abyssale 7 milliard
cent millions d'euros perdus envolée en
une seule année
de quoi donner le tournis air france
vient de passer une année noire à cause
du coc vide des avions cloués au sol par
manque de passagers 67 % de clients en
moins en 2020
georges tron s'apprête à passer sa
deuxième nuit en prison
la cour d'assises de paris a condamné en
appel l'ancien secrétaire d'état à cinq
ans de prison dont trois ans ferme pour
viol et agression sexuelle en réunion
contre l'une de ses anciennes
collaboratrices son adjointe à la
culture écopait de deux ans avec sursis
pour complicité
c'est un message de soulagement pour ma
cliente et c'est un message d'espoir
pour d'autres femmes qui sont dans cette
situation qui se complaît pas du tout
dans le statut de victime elle voulait
absolument s'en débarrasser c'est pas ça
qu'elle cherchait elle voulait passer à
autre chose
tous les moyens jusqu'à les hautes
sphères de l'état ont été utilisés pour
m'anéantir ça c'est une réalité moyen
des moyens des amitiés des cooptations
des copinages et beaucoup de pouvoirs
permettant d'user de tous les moyens
afin d'anéantir et de terre ma parole à
21h le robot persévérance de la nasa
doit se poser sur mars
après avoir parcouru 470 millions de
kilomètres depuis la terre il va
prélever des échantillons du site là de
façon à pouvoir les ramener sur terre et
les analyser le but de l'opération est
trop bien entendu de savoir si oui ou
non il y a eu de la vie sur mars